the real end shot that we ended up going
with
i the second that i read that i was like
oh
that's the end like that's you know i
know we could keep going and i know we
could we could make something out of
this but
my gosh is that an ending
[Music]
hey witches and welcome to et live's
farewell celebration for the chilling
adventures of sabrina
i'm leanna aguilera joined right now
with the bewitching kiernan shipka hey
karen
hi leanne how's it going everything's
good i'm so excited to have you on
fantastic i'm excited to be here i'm
here today with the cast
and we are so ready to dish out some
very exciting little tidbits about part
four of chaos
awesome let's get started let's do it
you're enjoying this
been back in action yeah
well karen first off how are you feeling
i feel like we're at the beginning of
the
end i am feeling good
i'm feeling bittersweet i think that
you know the uh the string of events
that happened with chaos
was interesting because we rapped
in early march late february early march
and within three weeks of rapping the
entire world seemed to shut down
seemingly overnight and i think
i had just been filming for 10 months i
had poured my heart and soul into the
show
and to just be in my house sitting with
all my feelings reflecting on
basically the past two and a half years
was
absolutely wild it was a lot
it was a lot to process but i'm happy
that i had time
to process rapping process the show
ending
officially and and now to be at a point
where i'm just so excited to share it
with people
it feels like kind of perfect
it feels like great closure i'm really
excited
to actually share it with the world i've
been holding such a good season i've
just been holding on to all these
spoilers for such a long time
i just want i just want to talk about it
like i was kind of getting to the point
where i was like okay guys can we just
put it outside
actually you know i i it's hard to not
talk about it
because there's so many exciting things
that happen and i have a hard time
distinguishing when they happen because
that's all such a blur
um but no needless to say i am just oh
above all else i am just thrilled for
people to finally be seeing it because
my fans deserve it and the fans have
been so passionate they love this show
so much
so what do you want to tease to them
about part four so much happens
oh my gosh i think fans are gonna get
everything they want and more
i think with two sabrinas uh
they are going to get double the fun and
you know
because there's two sabrinas there's
there's there's multiple people in her
life and there's multiple interactions
that i think people are going to find
very satisfying
that uh we couldn't do it just one i
could go to hell and visit sabrina
morningstar
darkness is going to consume greendale
in the entire world if we don't stop it
a threat to one of us is a threat to us
both this one kind of goes all the way
really you know
there's um it runs the gamut of
experienced um birth marriage
death everything it's all in there and
sabrina
we i think that's already been in the
trailer she turned 17.
[Music]
[Applause]
and yeah i remember having to do a
little
photo shoot for her birthdays i think
we're allowed to tell that because it's
very brief and it got to her 16th
birthday and we were pretending that you
know
that sabrina was 16 singing happy
birthday and i was like ah
enjoy your last year of niceness because
it's about to get really
savoriness being trixie your aunt hilda
worked very hard baking that cake yes
your favorite one
i'm not sure what happened of all the
stuff that you loved
in the first couple of seasons um
there's just a lot more it was ambitious
a very but let's just say it was it was
in terms of casting it was
hugely ambitious and i still can't
believe that they managed to pull off
a lot of new discoveries for for a lot
of characters
um and uh uh
some new magic to be found a lot of very
juicy and delicious alliances that
people may not see
come in also are you guys able to tease
the musical moment because
that was so cool one of many
very exciting musical moments my
favorite one
ever is coming up in this part and i'm
i'm
so excited about it i don't think we can
say anything because it's like the one
thing that netflix still hasn't um put
out
so i'm really really really really
really excited to like finally talk
about it because i've been telling all
my music friends like oh we get to do
something really cool but i can't tell
you what it is
but i'm so excited and it is so epic
robin gets to join the frank club in
like the most
cool way ever like jonathan like taking
on that part like what was that like for
you
that was fun i was really like it was
pretty nerve-wracking
to be honest with you because i'd never
really like done anything like that done
recording in a studio and done pre-lay
and
and come into that scenario feeling like
kind of i don't know i i was given so
much to like prepare
and like feel confident about that and
then we were actually doing it i was
like oh my god this is
so much fun like i could do this all day
because
we were also doing like a lot of the
scene work around that
moment and like we didn't really get to
actually do
the musical segment to the end and yeah
i just didn't want it to end
i knew that it was going to be a i knew
it was going to be this like very
sweet moment and i was going to look
back on it fondly and i still do i i
wish that i
yeah i wish i could do it again what can
you tease for the fans out there
about our two hell raising boys do we
get to see any team-ups this season
we definitely get into it this season me
and me and cal um i was gonna say
kalbrina
which is which is a hint for the fans
god knows uh
there's gonna be some calparina this
season but me and sam
spent a lot of time on set together this
season and michelle
too we're always together yeah there's
some beautiful camaraderie between the
whole lot there's some
episodes where the whole cast are
together and then there's uh
something that kind of divides us all
and uh it is a little bit hell versus
earth once again the fans are gonna see
what they've been like
dying to see i think we really wanted to
like
just get everything in that we could
into part four so like there's more
singing stuff
there's a lot of flirting and romance
and scary moments and epic moments and
uh um you know the eldritch terrors
which are fun
as hell to explore in each episode so
i think that you know they're just gonna
get what they've been waiting for and
it's finally here you promised me boys i
wanted you to meet my friends first
all the shippers will be happy at some
point in this season
this is so true i think i can say that
every single shipper will have their
moment
we paid homage to all of the ships i've
never
seen a show that has fans so
passionately shipping
so many different pairs was that
surprising to you when we
introduced nick to see just how much
things shifted in the fandom definitely
i think the it's it's so kind of even
funny for me to think about the fact
that the first
uh first part had
really like virtually zero nebrina
content
like i can't imagine the fandom without
nabrina being
a pillar i'd come onto the show with
like four episodes guaranteed with like
an option of four more after that
and i had no i had no way of knowing
that it was going to be
like this deep love affair with
with the show she was my first on-screen
kiss ever
i don't think i ever even kissed someone
on stage either
i'd always played like younger
characters so she was like my first
acting romance partner um
and yeah i do i do remember the last the
last kiss i'm just like
this is going to be the last time that
sabrina
or nick ever gavin or karen or whatever
this is
this is going to be the last time that
we kissed and i was like man
what a weird job i have and how funny
and here we are now you know yeah
oh my gosh i mean the ships the ships
make the show
the ships are great and sabrina's got a
little uh little complex
complex love life and that's fine she's
16 yeah
going on 17 that was one hell of a year
my goodness i think it i
think it rivals 2020. it really does
it's
like whatever whatever uh whatever date
she's
in they're in i think it rivals 20 20.
it i honestly feel like her from her
16th to her 17th birthday it must have
been over 2020 because the fact that all
that happened over a year is just
you know what it makes sense now because
people are always like oh what year is
this in
i think it is it was i think it answers
it
i think we've i think we have an answer
i think we finally figured it out
you can confirm particularly in this
season this season's very 2020.
uncut that was wonderful dear you're
going to fit right in here oh sabrina
this is going to be a laugh riot
want to see me do a spit take sorry
who are you over your aunties of course
i am so excited that the original
aunties
from sabrina the teenage witch were able
to join you guys
in part four for a special kind of
crossover anti-mishmash celebration
um what was it like for you ladies to
welcome them onto your turf and onto
your set
we were so excited but when they first
came up with the idea we thought oh wow
it sounds like an amazing idea but would
we ever be able to
cross over with you know another show
the intellectual property and then would
they be willing to do it would they be
kind enough to come onto our set and
work with us so
it seemed like such a cool idea but you
know in the back of my mind i thought
how are they ever going to make that
happen uh and then they did which was
just fantastic and it's a really
really clever funny script yeah
it is i i posted a picture on uh
instagram the other day of the four of
us and miranda and beth
who the two zeldas are sitting in the
back doing what zelda's would
think is right which is i've been told
to look at the camera lens
whereas the two hilda's in the front
[Laughter]
just and forgetting that you know
where we are and what we're going to be
doing and i love that picture
obviously you didn't necessarily know
that the part 4 finale was
the series finale were you able to snag
anything from set
no i have no material goods i have zero
zero cent memorabilia i
have i have certain gifts that were
given to me over time
from you know that are sabrina themed
from cast and crew and whatnot but i
have nothing
that's like i stole this from the set
where i
took this from the set i asked just for
like as a memory of
zelda could i get the cigarette holder
i'm not a smoker but it's just like
it's it's nice to have something small
to remember
like oh i'll take a whole you know
hulking
you know portrait from the wall or
something where am i gonna put that but
like something
tiny so i did ask for that and i'm
wondering if one day that
might arrive i asked for the teacups
what did i steal oh well i could show
you around this room but i'm not gonna
and there's just like small things uh
like my shoes and some of my some of my
um
i love my underwear um because it was
cute
um yeah basically shoes and underwear i
did however take
several pairs of underwear so wardrobe
department i'm so so sorry
um but they're the most comfortable
they're so
cozy and soft so i i am i think i'm
wearing a pair right now actually
i got those mambo marine rings
those are the ones
some costumes might have disappeared
but i i begged our costume designer
angus to let me keep a few things
and he basically just told me that he um
would look the other way jonathan please
tell me you got to keep your goblin ears
i wish you could have just grown i love
those ears
that was like ah man i it felt like it
was uh
like a glove you know what i mean like i
just felt like they were always supposed
to be there and oddly enough
when i put them on i was like able to
have more periphery in my hearing like i
could hear
it was weird like i people would kind of
come up behind me and i'd have this kind
of like
on-edge moment of being like this person
really close to me
um but if you think about it you know if
you cup your ears like it's it's the
same thing
but um i didn't get to keep anything
really cool
i was i was of the mind that we were
going to keep going i did try to steal a
picture of
of miranda i tried to steal a picture of
her in
in in character it was a beautiful
picture and it had a
gorgeous gilt edge frame and i got it
from the set to my trailer
and because i'm such a good girl and i'm
nothing like madam satan i started
sweating and i was like because you hear
that people do that you hear the actors
just
takes it well not if you're a working
class glaswegian that's been brought up
properly
so i was sweating like man i was
panicking and
i you wouldn't give it back i put it
back
you didn't at least ask if you could
keep it
now
i still look for like a hot second and
then i put it back this is like the most
anti-madam satan thing you've
ever done i am nothing like madam satan
i am the goofy father
i'm gonna try to see if they can go into
storage and at least send something
because
kind of a bum that i didn't i'm shocked
that you don't have at least your
headbands
i i don't know if i want to see the
headbands again i i don't i
i think i'm good
do you have an onset moment that you
think about that just brings a smile to
your face
uh one moment in particular that you're
always gonna cherish oh my goodness i
have so
many i would say that all those giant
group scenes
where we're all together and just a day
of shooting
one massive scene in the church of night
or
in the woods or something like that all
those memories
i just hold so close to my heart but one
that was particularly funny
was when luke
cook made us all do that dancing video
that we put out in the baxter high
hallway
and i remember that night so vividly
because it was the last night of
shooting before we went on a little
hiatus
and he was like guys like this is going
to be amazing we're going to do this and
we're all just going
no i don't know and then the second that
we started dancing
like everything you forget about
everything um
so just just being with everyone our
little jam sessions all of our hangouts
all of our
pranks i just that's not a concise
answer but i miss it all
there was a night that ross and i i'm
pretty sure this was like
like union might not enjoy this and i
might get a little slap on the back of
the hand for this later but that's okay
um but ross and i like slept
on set like not on set but like at the
studio where we were
filming i think what gavin probably
forgot to mention is that they actually
had a sleepover in my trailer
um basically to set the scene
we were filming a little bit further
away from town than usual probably like
an hour and a half out
and our call the next day was quite
early and gavin was like i think i'm
just gonna sleep here like
and i was like well i'm i'm going home
so if you want to take my trailer
go for it we're like sneaking in there
while the cleaning crew like came
through and did all that
and ross and i just like waited for
everyone to peace out it was like 1am
and then we just like walked around and
it was so
eerie that we were like we were we've
always been
at like the studio or wherever we were
shooting when loads of people are just
buzzing about all over the place you
know and for the first time i saw
a like our studio where all the magic
was kind of happening
completely barren and empty and it was
just ross and i like
um you know there was like a train
nearby and we like watched it go by and
we like had deep talks and we're just
like thinking about the whole experience
and what a
wild like ride it had been and it was
kind of near the end that
that had happened um where we just like
stayed overnight and then we woke up and
just got right to work and we were
bright-eyed and bushy-tailed and
wait that is amazing you had like a
bromantic sleepover
on instead of sabrina i did yeah they
had a moment they had their nice little
romantic sleepover and i showed up the
next day
at uh 8 a.m and said rise and shine
i felt like i'd get out of my trailer i
felt like it was a mom waking her kids
up like all right guys we gotta go
it's school time like let's get out so
geeks can uh
drink her coffee and be bearable to talk
to but
yeah i'm glad they had a nice time the
elders terrorists
our ancient entities they are well
destroyed
and there are more terrors yet to come
[Music]
culminating with the arrival of the void
when you read the part four finale
script
what was your immediate reaction
well there were different versions of
the script depending on whether or not
it was a finale or not but
the real end shot that we ended up going
with
i the second that i read that i was like
oh that's the end
like that's you know i know we could
keep going and i know we could we could
make something out of this but
my gosh is that an ending i haven't read
it and i haven't seen it
so i'm gonna i'm gonna find out with the
fans my reaction
oh my god the fans are going to be so
mad
that in like the best of ways like
it's like that finale is just
oh god i don't know how to like tease it
without spoiling it
oh yes well i screamed i did scream
and then i thought no there's no way
they're going to be able to pull that
off
you know what how kind of beautiful i
felt like
what a great send-off and an interesting
um
you know shakespearean kind of thing to
do
i think in some perfect way it ended up
being a really
good and and really powerful ending
um because it does leave you wanting
more
but with like us an acceptance i think
that'll come with the finale of
that we've been dealing with um all of
these big heady
sort of uh enemies and i think all of
that comes to a really
honest place so i think that's kind of
the perfect way to end it but i still
think
i think some people are gonna be a
little mad i think we were a little mad
that we were like
we want to do more and i think the fans
are going to want more i think i was the
only one with a sneaking suspicion that
we may be saying goodbye to each other
on that last day i was
crying and hugging people you were
really good because miranda said to me
about
two weeks before she had a theory of why
she didn't think we would be coming back
and it hadn't occurred to me
and we were outside about two in the
morning outside the salmon house
and i remember being in a bit of a daze
doing the the next few takes and i was
like
this is the last time i'm going to see
the sperm in the house and
i haven't occurred to me and i'm really
glad that she said it
because i was able everything we did for
the next three weeks i was able to go
this might be the last time
and so that was um you know especially
because we made lots of good friends in
vancouver
we had such a great crew um it was kind
of
weird to think that that little bubble
of life
wouldn't exist like that anymore um so
i'm i'm glad of miranda for that she's
always you're always the one miranda
that's good at like
your reader script and i think it's
because that's gonna happen i'm like
i don't think that yeah
i like it with all these things how do
you think the fans are gonna react to it
i think they're gonna be overwhelmed
with emotions because i was
um and i would i would think that they
would think similarly
um i think everyone will be happy
with it but also a little bit surprised
i was surprised
yeah i it's not a predictable one it's
not a predictable ending
it's not i didn't really see that coming
in any kind of way shape or form i think
it does wrap things up
but it certainly does not leave you
fully satisfied
in a good way my name is sabrina
spellman
[Music]
and i will not
sign it away
[Music]
here goes nothing well what do you hope
that
chilling adventures of sabrina's kind of
lasting legacy is going to be
with the fans when they think about the
show what do you hope comes to mind
i hope that people found joy in the show
and i hope that people found an escape
in this show and i i hope that this show
inspired
people to come into their own power and
and be the most unapologetic version of
themselves i really hope that
it inspires people to just live
fearlessly and boldly and
kindly at the end of the day well
that's our show thank you all so much
for tuning in to et live's
farewell celebration for the chilling
adventures of sabrina
kiernan how can fans watch sabrina's
final chapter filling adventures
of sabrina airs december 31st only on
netflix and you can stream it then and
forever
forever and be sure to check back to et
online immediately after you've binged
part four
for exclusive spoiler interviews with
kiernan and the rest of the cast
bye witches bye